meantime President Trump first suggested
last month that the Senate should repeal
Obamacare first that's a turnaround from
the plan he laid out in a 60 Minutes
interview after the election we're gonna
do it simultaneously it'll be just fine
we're not gonna have like a two-day
period and we're not gonna have a
two-year period where there's nothing it
will be repealed and replaced major
Garrett is at the White House where the
sudden collapse of the Senate bill was
unexpected to say the least good morning
to you major good morning the anatomy of
this failure begins with President
Trump's own inattention to detail he
rarely if ever immersed himself in the
finer points of health care policy or
the thorny politics behind that and
that's one of the reasons the president
and many around him last night were
surprised by the defections of Senators
Lee and Moran White House advisors tried
to shift focus away from this
conspicuous defeat by calling for a
repeal vote only on Obamacare and a move
at some point in the future toward tax
reform something senior officials here
at the White House discussed with Mitch
McConnell's office late last night a
president Trump who has always treated
Obamacare repeal more like a marketing
campaign than a legislative challenge
sounded oddly upbeat at the White House
yesterday unaware defeat was mere hours
away mr. Trump even lightheartedly
referred to ailing Senator John McCain
as a crusty voice in the Capitol whose
vote he desperately needed it turns out
the president needed far more votes than
that in the end the president never said
what he absolutely had to have in this
bill or what was unacceptable that left
lots of uncertainty and legislative
drift meanwhile the president's approval
ratings sunk to the lowest for any
president at this point in seventy years
so what's left for this White House to
tell its base of supporters that it's
Washington that is the problem not the
president that he's pushing against
entrenched interest and they're pushing
right back the big problem with that
charlie that creates more distance
between the president and congressional
Republicans which was a problem all
along good morning thanks major